it is perhaps
the world's most dangerous flashpoint
an island already determined to defend
itself that could bring the us and china
to war china says the island is part of
its territory
and has vowed to take it by force if
necessary
an uneasy status quo that has lasted 70
years
looks more difficult by the day in an
exclusive interview with sky news
taiwan's foreign minister said he feared
the worst they have been conducting
disinformation campaign hybrid warfare
and recently they have increased their
uh grazing activities against taiwan
and all these seem to be preparing for
their final
military assault against taiwan could
taiwan defend itself
under those circumstances when china is
such a big power
this is our country this is our people
and this is our way of life and we will
defend
ourselves to the very end and i should
also point out that taiwan happens to be
on the front line
in china's expansion of its
authoritarian order
and the taiwan is taken by china
i think the consequences will be global
but china insists that the issue of
taiwan is purely an internal affair
this is taiwan's declared air defense
identification zone
and this is where chinese jets have been
flying just in the month of april
twice in the same month china has also
sent an aircraft carrier to the other
side of taiwan
surrounding the island according to
mainland state media
in response the u.s navy has been
carrying out freedom of navigation
exercises through the taiwan strait
water that the uk's own aircraft carrier
will avoid
on its maiden voyage this summer for the
uk
to think about uh sending uh military
aircraft military uh surface ships to
this part of the world to
show that the uk cares is also welcomed
in this part of the world
france germany and canada are also
sending military ships to the region
these waters are becoming more congested
the possibility of miscalculation and
its consequences
more severe tom cheshire sky news
beijing